Owls are top predators, known for their excellent
hearing and eyesight.
But do these predatory birds keep these keen senses,
or lose them over time like most other animals?
To find out, researchers recorded data from
two groups of barn owls, young and old.
The birds were played tones to examine the
full range of their hearing.
When the owls heard a certain tone, they moved
to a different perch.
Compared to other animals that have been studied,
the barn owl’s hearing barely varied between the younger and older birds.
Hearing is accomplished in most animals via
hair cells:
Specialized cells with microscopic strands on top
that harness sound waves,
and send auditory signals to the brain.
Unlike mammalian hair cells, bird hair cells
regenerate gradually after trauma.
Because this is the second bird species found
to have “ageless ears,”
The other being the European starling,
the researchers suggest that birds do not experience hearing loss with old age.
Though more testing is required, the researchers
hope that the regenerative capabilities of
bird hearing could be used in human hearing
treatments, sometime in the future.